Firstly we'll need to update our parseAtlastDefinition function to take into
account if a sprite has been trimmed, using this data to modify the corner x and
corner y offset values. This is important because if you recall the coordinate
system of the canvas will place an image according to its top left corner. Well,
the trimming process in texture picker can move the top left corner to the new
trimmed location. As such, we need to refer to the trim data against the source
data to figure out what the proper offset is to draw the sprite in the correct
location. With this in mind you need to update the parse atlas definition to
take into account the differences between the framed version and the source
version to properly update the offset values so that the sprite draws in the
right location.